a
[Música]
ah
una tercera ola de contagios de kobe 19
inició en costa rica así lo confirmó el
ministro de salud a inicios de abril hay
un aumento considerable de casos y de
hospitalizaciones por coronavirus el
índice de positividad también aumentó
del total de pruebas que aplican las
autoridades el 25% resultan positivas el
jerarca dijo que de continuar el ascenso
de casos se tomarán algunas medidas como
la restricción vehicular- que se
flexibilizó cuando los casos bajaron
considerablemente la población ve con
preocupación el inicio de esta tercera
ola sobre todo porque recién pasó la
semana santa temporada en que los
costarricenses vacacionaron sin
restricciones en las playas y demás
destinos turísticos algunos temen que
ese relajamiento conlleve a un mayor
número de casos la comisión nacional de
vacunación redujo la reserva de vacunas
para acelerar la vacunación de la
población mientras que las autoridades
llaman a la ciudadanía a continuar
respetando las medidas como el
distanciamiento social y el uso de la
mascarilla
[Música]
uruguay registro por varios días
consecutivos la mayor cantidad de nuevos
casos de coronavirus por millón de
habitantes al tiempo que en el promedio
de los últimos siete días han fallecido
50 personas por día también el sistema
sanitario se encuentra al borde del
colapso tanto en la cantidad de camas
fármacos como médicos responsables para
los pacientes con la enfermedad del
grupo asesor honorario científico y
también varias instituciones académicas
le solicitaron al gobierno que éste
tomara medidas más restrictivas para
paliar la cantidad de contagios sin
embargo éste respondió que no va a
conformarse en un estado policíaco y por
lo tanto no ordenará el confinamiento de
la población el presidente luis lacalle
pou mantuvo la no presencialidad en las
escuelas el cierre de gimnasios freeshop
en la frontera y restricción en los
horarios de bares y restaurantes la
oposición dice que el gobierno está
priorizando la economía entretanto
el avance de la vacunación se está dando
en forma consistente en la población
pero los científicos indican que esto no
será suficiente para disminuir los
contagios
[Música]
el nuevo presidente de perú deberá
afrontar la tercera ola de la pandemia
el 19 que según las autoridades del país
se presentará entre mayo y junio sus
principales desafíos será implementar un
nuevo plan de vacunación y gestionar las
48 millones de dosis negociadas por el
gobierno de francisco sagasti el proceso
de la vacunación en perú es criticado
porque sólo han sido inmunizados
alrededor de 500 mil ciudadanos otro
aspecto importante será impulsar más
camas en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos así como oxígeno medicinal la
pandemia del nuevo coronavirus dejó en
evidencia una aguda crisis en el sistema
sanitario del país el nuevo mandatario
también deberá reactivar la economía que
debido a la emergencia del cobre 19 cayó
11 por ciento en su producto bruto
interno además tendrá que impulsar las
actividades productivas del perú y
generar nuevas fuentes de empleo según
cifras oficiales más de 2 millones de
peruanos perdieron su puestos de trabajo
por la crisis
[Música]